[Musica]
freddo ora magari non esattamente qui ma
dieci metri da qui se aprite la porta
uscite fuori sentite freddo voi sapete
di che cosa parlo tant'è che nessuno e
nessuno di voi è venuto qui maniche
corte o in pantaloncini corti nessuno di
voi e oggi in costume da bagno perché
fuori come si dice dalle mie parti fa un
ghiaccio boglione per il freddo fuori la
notte si muore tre giorni fa è morto a
roma un ragazzo di 30 anni è
praticamente un uomo perché a 30 anni
sempre uomini che ai ragazzi ed è morto
davvero tre giorni fa non ho detto tre
giorni fa perché crea empatia la
vicinanza temporale
no no è che se ad esempio tede fosse
stato dopodomani io probabilmente in
quel caso invece avrei detto è morto
ieri ma non avrei mentito perché
d'inverno muore più o meno per le
conseguenze del freddo una persona ogni
tre o quattro giorni sapete come si
chiamava questo ragazzo di 30 anni morto
a roma non lo sapete ma non lo so
neanche io perché chi muore di freddo
fuori molto spesso ha il nome nascosto
dai pregiudizi e questo è un bel
problema
dice è la sua stagione
il freddo d'inverno
avete mai sentito dire cioè d'inverno e
freddo e d'estate è caldo di solito è
così ad esempio potremmo smettere di
chiamare emergenza freddo tutti i piani
di aiuto alle persone senza dimora che
si svolgono durante l'arco dell'inverno
perché se succede tutti gli anni in
tutti gli inverni allora non è più un
emergenza sarebbe un emergenza se un
giorno non ci fosse più l'inverno dove
cazzo sei andato inverno è invece
l'inverno cioè tutti gli anni
dove eravamo rimasti alla gente che
fuori muore oppure se li va bene non
muore e sopravvive però si tratta di una
sopravvivenza ad esempio vengono i
geloni alle mani i geloni ai piedi
camminano male mangiano di merda non
sanno dove pisciare hanno problemi
psicologici psichiatrici molti fanno uso
di sostanze tossiche sono alcolisti un
sacco di problemi
i senza dimora sono pieni di problemi
non ne hanno uno solo non è solo che
dormono fuori
e allora molte persone hanno imparato ad
essere cintura nera di evitare di vedere
le persone fuori per strada quelli che
dormono fuori e sono così bravi a non
vederle che quando invece scorgono delle
coperte ad esempio piegato in un angolo
le buttano via lo chiamano il decoro il
decoro dei ricchi che i poveri li danno
sempre fastidio ai ricchi anche se
insomma un pò strano questa cosa perché
molti sono ricchi proprio perché hanno
creato un sacco di poveri e poi li da
noi a vederli che se fosse una
barzelletta sarebbe da ridere invece un
fatto serio ea me mi fa girare in
corbezzoli e proprio perché mi giravano
in corbezzoli due anni e mezzo fa ho
fondato ship italia che è
un'associazione che poi è diventata
onlus e che a migliaia di persone in
tutta italia che provano a dare una mano
per cambiare dei pezzi dell'esistente di
un periodo che va dal primo settembre al
15 novembre noi tutti gli anni chiediamo
di spedirci dei quadratini di lana di 15
cm x 15 cm oppure già assemblati in
coperte oppure se non solo assemblato in
coperte le assemblano le nostre
volontarie e i nostri pochi volontari al
maschile nelle zone di firenze prato
pistoia è incredibile anche empoli a noi
poi distribuiamo queste coperte alle
persone che stanno fuori lei è una
nostra volontaria storica che non sta
incredibilmente meglio di una persona
che vive fuori ma trova il cuore così
grande per lasciare spazio ad altri play
la mitica la invece e quelli sono i
pacchi e arrivati un sesto dei pacchi
arrivati in quest anno il totale che
oltre 1400 e poi qui siamo un pezzettino
di noi quando proviamo ad aprire i
pacchi ea mettere le coperte in delle
shopper poi portarli oppure dei
quadratini che dividiamo in delle
shopper che poi appunto vengono
assemblate in coperte coperte che ha
sembrano ad esempio signore come queste
quando noi diamo la shopper con i
quadratini noi copriamo corpi
infreddoliti e contemporaneamente
proviamo a trovare a cercare una
relazione con le persone ad esempio
quando abbiamo per strada noi facciamo
scegliere il colore della coperta e di
solito la reazione sulla scelta del
colore della coperta è una cosa del tipo
non importa non perdonò colore è uguale
dai coperta dai e noi invece a quel
punto diciamo no è molto importante che
tu scelga il colore e iniziamo a tirarle
fuori dalle nostre shopper e facciamo un
pò lo show iniziavamo guarda malawi
quale preferisci guardava e tocca lo
tocca la sente anche un compito e tocca
lo stesso mentre qui e di là l poi le
persone scelgono sono persone
disabituata la possibilità di scegliere
non scelgono nemmeno cosa mangiare non
scelgono quando mangiare almeno la
possibilità di poter scegliere le
coperte un modo per iniziare una
relazione perché dalla scelta delle
coperte poi c'è sempre una nonna nazi a
una mamma qualche volta un nonno che
lavorava la maglia o talvolta almeno
usciva insomma che aveva a che fare con
i tessuti e lì è la possibilità di
scambiare delle storiche esattamente
quello che stiamo facendo oggi ieri sera
noi abbiamo distribuito 65 coperte a
firenze vicoli ieri sera perché davvero
ieri sera e domani sera perché davvero
domani sera saremo invece a empoli a
distribuirle insieme alla croce rossa
noi ci portiamo sempre ad altre
associazioni gruppi che operano con le
persone che dormono fuori durante tutto
l'anno
li accompagniamo e diamo pezzi di calore
questa è una delle situazioni incontrate
a quest anno a padova una signora che
diceva aspettava il treno la mattina
dopo lei non avrebbe dormito fuori cioè
o comunque sì ma solo quella sera lei
non era una senza dimora
chi ci ha l'occhio lungo capisce invece
è uno schermo che uno si prova a mettere
di fronte una sorta di autoprotezione lì
s'è detto vabbè anche se però non sei
senza dimora ma dorme fuori stanotte e
prendi questa coperta e allora alla fine
è appreso i due scegliendone il colore
poi la mattina dopo alle 10 l'abbiamo
ritrovata sempre lì perché non aveva
nessun treno da prendere oppure il treno
che doveva prendere le aveva perso
diversi anni fa
quindi stiamo alla scelta del colore qui
proviamo ad avvicinarci alle persone
sono io e ma basso fregarlo in questo
modo anche la telecamera
e lui sta giù perché il poco calore
conquistato è un calore da tenere e
anche il gesto di alzarsi ti fa perdere
quel calore che avevi fino a quel
momento è lo stesso motivo per cui ad
esempio loro sorridono ma mica tutti
sorridono loro sì ma loro già meno loro
vivono con una stufa accanto male una
stufa tenuta su da una bottiglia di
plastica riempita d'acqua che deve
servire a tenere il tappo della stufa
premuto se la bottiglia d'acqua scivola
voi sapete come sono altre bottiglie
d'acqua che sono tutte trombettiere
possa accadere a loro li s'apre la stufa
e mogliano e non è un caso perché tutti
gli anni muore qualcuno affumicato in
questa maniera nei campi alle nostre
periferie lei ad esempio e lui solo alla
periferia di sesto fiorentino
lei si china per mettere la coperta
addosso alla persona non è un gesto
paternalistico o maternali stico non non
lo facciamo perché noi siamo più alte
nella diamo e sempre per non far perdere
alla persona il calore conquistato fino
a quel momento poi c'è chi il calore
conquistato fino a quel momento provo a
non perderlo in questa maniera questo
invece l'ho fotografato perché dentro
c'è una persona alla fortezza a firenze
dove ora c'è la mega bellissima fra
l'altro ma quanto è bella la ruota
panoramica lì dentro si chiuda in
quest'uomo tutte le notti e poi si
chiude ancora meglio con lo scotch e da
lì dentro prova ad arrivare fino alla
mattina e se tu li provi ad offrire ad
esempio il tè caldo che dice lui no e lo
sapete perché dice no perché poi li
scapperebbe la pipì e in quei contesti
riuscire a scoprirsi e ad andare a fare
pipì è troppo lungo e implica il mettere
in disequilibrio la possibilità della
sua sopravvivenza
una cosa ci tengo molto a dirla come
chef italia noi non facciamo carità non
ce ne importa nulla della carità noi lo
facciamo per un piccolo minimo e
minimale senso di giustizia
noi non facciamo carità non siamo angeli
tra l'altro ci divertiamo anche facendo
e proviamo a raccontarci le storie con
le persone che incontriamo e anche
questo è molto divertente
non lo facciamo come fustigazione perchè
altrimenti andiamo all'inferno
all'inferno tra l'altro credo non ci
bada nessuno l'inferno sia vuoto come
ognuno questo la pensi come vuole chi se
ne frega noi lo facciamo perché ci
scappa da ridere quando siamo con le
persone belle e qualche volta ci scappa
anche da piangere ad esempio di tina
l'ho incontrata alla stazione di milano
a rogoredo e di dean aveva gli occhi in
alto come succede alle persone che si
iniettano l'eroina quando sono sotto
l'effetto provavo a scendere gli scalini
della stazione di rogoredo e stava per
cascare e da lontano non troppo un altro
suo compagno non d'avventura ma di
disavventura le urla di dina rgt lei
allora prende la mano e afferra un
sostegno di ferro che sa come chissà
perché in quel momento accanto a lei di
denham a rimasta dentro perché compiva
40 anni a gennaio lo scorso anno e disse
che per i suoi 40 anni voleva regalarsi
l'entrata in una comunità la rivista
quest'anno sta per compiere 41 anni e in
comunità non c'è entrata perché mica
tutte le storie finiscono bene e hanno
la necessità dell'applauso in fondo e
poi mi ricordo orlando orlando invece di
roma urlando tiene la sua mamma in
braccio la mamma sa 94 anni e le fa
scendere tutte le scale stanno al quinto
piano e io gli ho chiesto orlando ma non
potevi pinar l'ascensore e lui mi dice
l'ascensore non ci sta e già che
imbecille me ne ero scordato
manciano nemmeno la corrente elettrica
in casa hanno le finestre rotte perciò
proviamo a dare qualche coperta anche a
loro perché anche se sta in un edificio
quando le finestre sono rotte che entra
entra l'aria fredda e poi mi ricordo
luigi luisi invece io la prima volta
l'avevo scambiato per un volontario
perché mi capisci di noemi fa saverio fa
io vedo tutti i tuoi video perché
cellulari ce l'hanno anche loro è non è
che il cellulare comincerebbe a nessuno
11 cellulare allora è ricco no ma ci
pare ci sanno tutti che fa vedere tuoi
video bravo eccetera e poi fa io conosco
firenze brusco la stazione di campo di
marte a li faccio campo di marte un po
lontane realta da casa mia però sì o
presente anch'io quella zona lì e poi mi
dice conosco anche la stazione quella di
santa maria novella e io inizio a
guardarlo poi mi fa conosco la stazione
d'arezzo e lì qualcosa mi viene in mente
e poi mi dice conosco benissimo la
stazione di lucca e allora capiscono in
lui era uno di quelli e frequenta la
stazione per trovare un posto e un
riparo dove dormire c'è una frase che mi
piace molto l'ho scritta io
che non è un granché da dire come cosa
vedete chi si salva nella vita e perché
una persona che chi si salva nella vita
e meno male l'ho letta cioè la linea
frase provavo a leggere chi si salva
nella vita è sempre una persona che ha
avuto qualcuno intorno che ha fatto caso
ai suoi particolari
maremma sul suo complessità ed avranno
ha detto nessuno alt ed ex mare ma su
ciò è stata la seconda gamba di scippi
talia sono i gruppi di insegnamento del
lavoro a maglia
loro sono delle signore in una casa di
riposo non proviamo a farle riposare
pochissimo ea metterle al lavoro
tantissimo abbiamo cinque gruppi attivi
due incrociano riguardano la salute
mentale poi le persone anziane o sole
oppure donne rifugiate come in questo
caso è vittime di tratta perché quando
le donne sono rifugiate sono quasi
sempre vittime di tratta non si tratta
che son venute qui a invaderci ma che
invaderci sono minute via provare a
salvarsi
queste invece sono delle borse lavoro
questo è la nostra questa è la nostra
terza gamba abbiamo costruito un
percorso con delle donne in cui
insegniamo loro a lavorare con la
macchina da cucire sono delle persone in
situazioni di vulnerabilità ma belle
forti e capaci e capaci perciò anche di
imparare e di emanciparsi sono quattro
ma venerdì in questa foto è di venerdì
una era malata e siccome noi si insegna
il lavoro e si sente quando uno è malato
e il giusto che stia a casa lei era
rimasta a casa e loro hanno degli
alberini di natale con cui poi sarebbero
andate a fare un mercato
pochi o poche ore dopo qui invece
berlusconi dato invece bellissimo ci
hanno in mano il loro primo buono un
buono da 250 euro di spesa alimenti che
noi garantiamo per permettere loro di
venire con più tranquillità a
frequentare la borsa lavoro che va dal
lunedì al venerdì dalle 9 alle 13 tutti
i giorni
io mi chiamo saverio tommasi
racconto storie con la mia videocamerina
per fanpage.it sono un giornalista e
scrivo libri per feltrinelli se
parlassimo a livello di carriera
potremmo dire che io sono già arrivato e
io ho fondato ship italia dopo che ero
arrivato non ho fondato un'associazione
per provare ad arrivare ho fatto
esattamente il percorso inverso
non prendo un centesimo da ship italia
ci metto tanto sudore come ora
è però è impagabile la bellezza di poter
parlare ad esempio alle bambine e
bambini delle scuole primarie qui sono a
torino settimana scorsa tutte robe
recenti e c'era un bambino andrea che a
un certo punto allo spazio domanda è
alzato la mano e ha detto ma
perché esistono i soldi se ci sono i
poveri è cazzo andrea
ho amato molto quel bambino io mi chiamo
saverio tommasi vi ricordo che scheep
italia vive di donazioni esclusivamente
private piccole donazioni o ancora 4
minuti perciò per 4 minuti vi ridirò
questa cosa shipp italia vive di piccole
donazioni private
no due volte è sufficiente
vi auguro un buon cammino a tutte ea
tutti ci proviamo a incrociare negli
interstizi delle vite buone intrecci a
tutte ea tutti grazie
[Applauso]